We'll bother pushing the video now because I've
accidentally just pushed myself to the front. Hello.
Welcome to the Rawkode Academy.
This is our second episode of clustered this
week
And we have two great clusters, two great
guests, and I'm looking forward to fixing some
very broken clusters.
Thank you to everyone who's tuning into the
chat. I'll get your messages up in just
a second. But before we do that, I
do wanna say hello and thank you to
our sponsors.
So since the beginning of Clustered, we have
been using Teleport. And almost since the beginning,
Teleport have been sponsor and Clustered.
And I really just can't thank them enough.
I generally believe that Teleport is a product,
an open source tool that you don't even
need to pay for, that everyone should have
in their infrastructure to commoditize access, facilitate pairing
and debugging.
You'll see us use that today.
I also need to thank Equinix Medal. They
continue to graciously provide all of the hardware
that we use for these three node bare
metal Kubernetes clusters with tons of RAM and
tons of CPU.
Is it all necessary for clustered?
Hell no. But is it fun? Damn right.
So thank you Equinix Metal.
Alright. Let's get some chat messages on the
screen and bring in our guest today.
Push the button.
There we go. I am having an absolute
failure of the button presses today. I think
it's because it's a Friday and it's like
05:30 and my brain is clearly just switched
off. However,
welcome, Adrian. Welcome, William. Thank you both for
joining me again. You're both returning cluster clusters.
Let's
start with some hellos. We'll start with you,
Adrian, and then over to William. Please introduce
yourselves.
Yeah. Hello. My name is Adrian.
Been doing Kubernetes things for quite a while
now. Not anymore, which is interesting. Doing back
to back end development since recently.
Yeah, look forward to
mess around with some clusters.
I currently work at field. They are looking
for infrastructure engineers. They told me to plug
that if you they
asked me, and I said, no. I want
to do back end stuff.
And, yeah, I'm looking for it.
How
to see you struggle and
or not.
Yeah. Awesome. Thank you very much. William?
I'm William Lightning. I'm from Field Medical. I'm
a systems architect, and
my job is to fix things
and be responsible for the infrastructure and
basically
stuff like that.
So I'm I'm always looking forward to learning
new things and learning about new brakes before
I see them in production.
Awesome. Thank you both for sharing with us.
Alright. We're gonna kick things off
with
William. We're gonna be taking a look at
Adyen's cluster. If you've not joined us before,
the rules are simple.
Fix the cluster via any means necessary. In
order to fix it, all we mean is
you have to be able to upgrade the
clustered application from v one to v two.
My screen is now shared. I have opened
a session via Teleport's command line application.
And if you could join this session oh,
I haven't.
You don't even have access to the cluster,
do you William?
Nope.
Alright. That's because I'm sneaky and I don't
give you access beforehand.
So I'm gonna come in and modify your
role.
Very professional setup I've got here as you
can tell. However, it does mean I get
to show off a
teleport a bit more. So we restrict your
access with node labels.
And if I save this, refresh your server
list and you should have access.
And I will join from the web too
because we'll have them at some point and
there's a weird bug.
Alright. If you can just give me an
echo hello.
Say I have your cube config.
Check for a control plane and take it
away and best of luck.
Let's see here. Cube config. I always forget.
Does it have a
underscore in there or not? No. It doesn't.
It's just as as is. That's perfect.
Let's just start with a Nope.
No control plane.
Oh. There we go. One control plane. Good.
Oh, it's it's halfway through migrating something. Alright.
Well, that's
Yeah.
Let's see here. Should I go for rollout
status?
Alright. Let's just describe the describe the deploy,
clustered.
Let's just look at what we have here.
So we're still in v1,
minimum replicas,
unavailable progressing,
progress deadline, okay.
So
let's go back.
What if I roll back the deployment?
Yeah. I think it's worth a shot.
Roll back? Roll out
and then
yeah. I don't think we used do a
dash dash help on that. I can't remember.
Okay.
Undo. There you go.
Undo.
Okay.
Let's check out our pods.
So we also have pending. Everything's pending.
Oh, rolling back just created another one.
No, it's the same ones I Let's
check out all namespaces. Let's just look around.
So we got ciliums
and image pulled back off. I wish people
would stop messing with cilium.
What does cilium ever do to you, Arlene?
Come on.
Well, Selium is
oops.
Gotta
describe get deployments of all namespaces and that
should
we got the cilium operator.
Describe cilium operators. That's gonna be in the
cube system.
You can tell I'm not using tab complete.
Making a lot of interesting fun problems
to play.
Let's try.
Let's see if it it it is less
mess with things. There we go. No. I
no. I encourage less as much as possible.
It just means we see what you see.
So Yeah.
Operator generic.
So that is from cine cilium at least.
Right?
What's
you know what? I'm just gonna go
get rid of this.
Let's just edit it because then I get
them.
And I get an actual YAML file, which
is what I'm used to seeing.
So type rolling update.
So I'm wondering
I guess we should look at the logs.
That's probably what I should do. Well, what's
the what's the first symptom you wanna investigate
here?
Is it depending pods? Is it are you
just fixing Cilium because you see that it's
got a problem? Or, like, what's your Well,
figured the pods
well, if Cilium has a problem, then
I can't get networking, which means the pods
might not come up right. And so I'm
I'm trying to skip past
the pods being the problem and looking for
root issues.
But I'm not sure that's
because it's let's see here. If I go
get pods. Right?
Postgres is still running, but clustered is not.
And a hundred and thirty six minutes means
that
all those are fairly recent,
But they're
yeah.
So I'm trying to figure out, like, do
I wanna go back and look at the
networking or do I wanna look at pod?
I suspect let's confirm the events. Right? We
could we could
describe the pod and see why it's not
not loading. Yeah. I think that's a good
idea. I mean, I think networking is an
issue, but depending
leads me to think maybe
nodes unavailability,
tents.
Yeah. There we go.
Got two. One of had it.
The notepod didn't tolerate two nodes, had paint,
not ready. Okay. So
the master, that's expected
because we have the control plane. Right? But
the workers are both not ready. Yeah. That
see if control follow that. Let's
go look at our notes.
Yeah. They're broken.
You asked me to break it, so I
break it. That's
Well,
that's what we asked you to do. Right?
I don't know.
I'm always worried I'm gonna break it and
then not know how I broke it.
So
CPU limits good. Memory limits good. Not that
that's necessarily.
Container runtime not ready.
CNI plugin not initialized.
So we're back at our our our CNI.
Right? Our container network interface.
Yeah. We are indeed.
Alright.
But at least now we know why we're
looking into the networking.
Yeah. Instead of just jumping ahead.
Okay. So then
I I should go look at my mycelium
stuff. Right?
I'm gonna say
no.
I I don't know. Like, it's it's tough.
Right? I I I don't know what's broken
just as you don't know what's broken. And
there's definitely a psyllium issue.
The thing is popping into my head is
that we got all the nodes are not
ready. We've got a whole bunch of pods
and a pending and terminating status,
which makes me think that we might not
even have a cubelet, which is why the
pods are so stuck
on the Yeah. The control plane's not even
ready yet. That should be at least ready.
Let's look at the well, let's let's let
me look at that.
Ripe node.
Type two. No. Not available.
You can look at completions. How I look.
Left.
Okay. So
CNI plugin not initialized.
because that's not an Etsy
Kubernetes
manifest. Right? That's not you don't usually put
that in there.
Trying to remember. Because Helium is just an
a Helm chart you deploy into your cluster.
Right?
That is correct. Yes.
So
that means So it would have bypass.
Right. Well, it means we need a cubelet
to start cilium and if there's no cubelet
on any of the nodes or the control
plane node then we'll never get a work
in CNA.
We do appear to have one.
Okay.
I don't know.
Okay. So that IP does exist on the
on the server. That's what I was looking
at there.
Maybe check a look at the kiblet logs.
That's gonna be in system system control. Right?
Yeah. Correct.
I don't know. System control.
Oh, that's everything.
Is it logs?
No. You can do journal control dash flu
kubelet.
Flu, f l u. Sorry.
My Scottish accent there.
There we go.
Okay.
CNA, pipes pod syncing pod skipped.
Okay. What are we what are you?
Okay. So it's definitely Isn't there a way
that
that,
Thelium is skipping
that not ready because the c n I
plug
in would not be ready before Selium is
ready.
So
this comes down to the way the CNI
initializes itself,
which I will say my knowledge of it
is not great. But the kubelet will start
this delay in pod which will actually put
some binaries onto the host. And as those
binaries exist,
then the CNI would be considered initialized.
And I'm assuming that those binaries do not
exist. So what you probably need to do
right now is because there's a working couplet
as a
take a look at the logs and start
debugging that silly and pod. So the thing
you were doing like five minutes ago and
I dragged you down the wrong path, not
the wrong path but I I made you
take the longer road, I think, there.
So oops. Sorry.
All about showing people things.
If I'm going too fast, I can't show
people. Yeah. Okay. System.
Celium. Let's go
you wanna go let's go let's check.
Yeah. You won't get let's say image pulled
back off.
Don't know if you said that. Yeah.
So you need to describe operators what you're
talking about. I know that the operators are
actually okay, but if you look at the
three selium pods on the three nodes, their
image pull back off. So I think we'll
need to describe those pods.
Type in while people are watching is the
fun thing. Right?
Yeah.
So I think this is okay. So if
I remember correctly,
this is the right image. But I'm wondering
if he did something to the actual worker
node
to make it so that it couldn't pull
the pod. I
think that's a typo in the image.
And part of me just wants to grab
the Helm chart for Cilium and redeploy it.
No. Let let's do an edit of the
Cilium deployment.
Okay. This is so Clay dot you think
there's a typo in that image there?
Not there, but at another part of the
image. So I think that in it container
is okay. But the look at the message
at the bottom there.
Cilium x.
Okay.
Alright. So let's check out the deploy because
that's gonna be what has it. Right?
Yeah. I think so.
Because the the the pod itself is just
gonna
I think it's a demon set.
Oh.
There we go. So
I see okay. So let's go find what
we want.
You said there was a x in there.
Okay. There's the x right there.
Yeah.
I would just remove it.
Just remove it? Just the x. Yeah.
Alright.
Do we think he's only changed one image?
No. But
what do we have here?
So warnings,
but none of those none of those should
stop us. Okay. No. Those look I don't
wanna say safe, but they're they're not issues
yet. Oh, there we go.
Problem one fixed.
And look, all our all our Kubernetes came
back online and Wow. Reconciled.
Amazing.
All of our nodes are happy. Oh.
That's it's like dangerously positive.
Like
okay.
So
can we get to the website?
I guess that's the question. Can we get
to the existing one? You can curl on
local host port 30000.
That one?
So the answer is no.
Well, I'll just confirm with one of the
workers.
Oh, yeah. That's true because I'm on a
control plane.
It is not working.
Yep. It's time of it. So
not quite there yet.
Well, do we wanna save a little time
and update our deployment so we go to
our v two clustered? But once we do
get things, we're gonna roll out.
Sounds good to me? No. No.
Go for it.
Alright. So
we're gonna go
too many v ones in here. There it
is.
We'll replace that with a two,
and we'll write this out.
And
in fact, I'm gonna take off my old
namespaces switch.
I love watching. So there's our error message.
Well, it was a very long time out.
But we can see
It's failing to look up Something's happening. Right?
Yeah. It's failing to look up the database.
Do we have any network policies?
Helium supports network policies. Right? It does indeed.
Yeah.
K. I also support cluster wide network Exactly.
Yeah. CCNP.
K.
I'm going to type this correctly.
NP.
Yeah.
Oh, network policy thinks so. Okay. No resources
found. Okay.
So
our two
our postgres goal and our clustered are not
talking to each other basically is what it
comes down to right now. Yeah. Right? So,
like, clustered pod expects there to be a
service called postgres.
Let's look at our look at our services.
There is a service there. That's good.
Age is a bit different than everything else.
Always a bad sign. Always.
Let's let's
go check it out.
Actually, probably ought to describe it first.
Throw that in the left so we can
see. Oh, there's not a whole lot there.
That's not the right port. I know that
right off the top of my head.
is not right. You you do $80.80 on
yours. That's for the web application. Postgres does
run-in 5432.
You're right. You're right. Okay. Dang. Oh, I
was gonna It does have endpoints with which
makes me think that the service
might
be okay.
Okay.
I mean, I say that may, of course,
that's my, like, a JLC card, but it
looks alright for me.
Okay.
What's our next hypothesis?
Well, I was wondering if I could
I know Kubernetes debug is a new stuff.
Does your clustered pod have a shell that
I can get into? Yeah. I leave bash
in there, so you should be okay.
Okay.
Gonna be our pod here.
But you will need to dash IT.
I do I probably need to do that
before the pod. Yeah.
I think so.
Oh, I love this. My
home and end key work.
Mac always broke my home and end key.
Of course, I spoke too soon now that
I've got
some weird stuff going on with the shell.
Oh, no. I'm in I'm inside of it.
You are. Yeah. Okay. I'm inside. Yeah. That
worked.
Okay. So
I I think
yeah. You should be able to do an
app update and install whatever you need.
I'm not harsh. It's not distroless. It's it's
not scratch. It's a
although there's there's an issue.
So no networking
at all.
Yep. That that that is a bit surprising
to me as well, but it's fine.
Or is it? Wait. I haven't I haven't
I would have expected networking to work in
in the pod, interestingly enough.
Net networking in Kubernetes
can be challenging. So Well yeah.
Alright. So we've got no egress from this
pod whatsoever,
which would explain why it's unable to speak
to Postgres. So we need to track that
down.
Well, I didn't start on that one.
Because we looked for network policies. We looked
at all that stuff.
Well, let's look at the logs real fast
for that pod. Right? There's nothing. Should get
us. Cluster clogs nothing. I I I keep
every time someone tries to look at the
logs, I'm like, I really need to add
logging. This is so unfair. The
Celeum has a conflict map.
I would maybe suggest
there.
Oh,
yeah. That's good. Yeah. I see they're gonna
be the Celeum configuration or IP tables on
the hosts perhaps.
I mean,
we'll need to check both, I think.
Okay. So Celium config
and cube system.
And we're gonna go for a Selium config.
I cannot spell Selium, so I'm gonna cut
and paste.
Show me the channel.
Look at all that fun stuff.
Nobody's ever broken a Celium on me before,
so this is new.
New fun stuff.
So it's not in debug mode.
Auto direct node routes.
From here is I don't have
a known good version of this
to compare against.
Do any of the flags sound ominous to
you?
Well, always
sounds ominous, but
I think that one's safe in this case.
IPv four true, IPv six false.
Policy's default.
If you need hints, by the way, there
are three hints in the home directory.
You don't have to use them yet. They
they are just there, just so you know.
I'm not completely evil.
Just a bit. Well, I'm I'm only three
minutes to my halfway point.
Yeah. Exactly. So
let's see here.
So the only thing in here
that I can never remember
and we kinda glossed over it there is
the enable policy default.
Now
I think that's actually correct at at default.
If my understanding is correct
then everything is allowed until a policy exists
and then at which case is they
block all until allowed or something like that.
So I I don't think it's silly, but
I'm not a % sure.
Am I allowed to bring up the comp
on my on my other cluster and
and look and compare it. I mean,
I I you would do that in your
real job. Right?
Yeah. So go for it.
Always go for the known good and comparing
the Exactly. Good with the Yeah. Feel free
to dump it out on your own and
then drop it into a fail on this
terminal and run a diff and
and see. Okay. Let's see if I can
figure out how to do that.
Oh, I like that. Run a diff. Run
a diff is always the best way to
go. Okay. So I just did
yeah.
I can just cut and copy this command.
I don't even need to Oh, a really
cool comment from Walid as well in the
chat. Just while you're playing with our cluster
is we do. Did we add k as
an alias? I don't think it did.
It's not deployed. Oh, well.
Well, you just said Hubble was enabled on
the config.
Well, he just write. However, it has not
deployed to our cluster.
I can't remember if I You don't you
don't enable Hubble, though. Right? I've never seen
you do that. I should though. It's super
cool for seeing why network traffic is not
going where you want it to go.
Is that the UI
thingy from Cilium? It is. Yeah. The other
thing we could do is use the Cilium
CLI tool to run a status and a
you know, everything that Hubble does, you can
do with the Cilium CLI as well.
Is that installed? No. You'd have to go
into a Cilium pod and run a Cilium
status.
But stick with your diff first. I think
that's like that feels like something I would
do and you would do it in real
life, so let's try it. Okay. So
there it is.
So now we're gonna take this a bunch
of things are gonna actually diff on this.
I don't know. Well, unknown unknown bads. Right?
Yeah.
Okay. That's none of those things or things
are gonna cause us any problems. That is
clean.
So it's not Alright. Well, it's not not
silly, but it's
mildly confident. It's not silly.
So how is your Linux networking knowledge?
It's old.
Wow. I remember that command. That's always good.
Let's see here. I need to go on
the left for this. I mean, this I
mean, just looking at the IP tables and
seeing in
the firewall, is there anything weird here?
Anywhere.
So one of the things I encouraged last
week on an episode was just to flush
the tables and let the cube proxy and
sell them back up.
However, that does get us into more trouble.
But it's normally safe to do that. You
so you could do that if you wanted.
I
think it would be okay.
I think so too. You
think so too. Yeah. So just do an
IP table dash capital f and that'll flush
all the rules and then Cillium will put
back the ones that it needs for networking
to work.
If if if you think it's a firewall
thing
at least. Okay.
IP tables dash capital f.
F for flush.
Yep.
And then if you run dash l again,
it should be
there we go. We have clean IP tables.
So
but that that should come back automatically. Right?
Because it'll take there's noted tables and then
Well, I mean, this is better than last
week because we get kicked off the machine
last time. So you're still able to type
commands, which is cool. So Yay.
So you could try your curl again, I
suppose.
Well, if there's no rules on IP tables,
that's not good.
It's not bad either. Right.
Yep. Is it? We might have to restart
Cillium, I think, for the rules to be.
But
But I don't think we need the rules
just yet.
I I don't know either. Oh,
well. We're still getting a table now. So
yeah. It's still saving that.
Oh, well, better what I got last time.
Okay. Let's kill off the helium pods and
see what happens.
When in doubt in Kubernetes, kill the pod.
That's what I learned from you.
I'm really glad that custard is teaching people
these viable production skills.
Delete.
Yeah. Just
smash, smash, smash. Yeah. You can use that
or you can copy paste it. Go for
that.
Can you start with that? No. But you
could do dash l app equals psyllium and
that would also do it.
Right.
Pod.
You've got delete delete.
Oh, I do.
Just when one delete is not enough, go
with two. That's a good rule too.
I so badly want to like involve my
my Google voice
and like breaking the cluster live for you
guys. That would have been fun.
Yeah. Where you could just say,
okay thing
destroy. I was I was was gonna be
like, okay thing, engage
or activate contingency plan alpha. And then I
said, sorry, Dave. I can't do that. I'd
be like, oh, okay thing,
pseudo activate
contingency plan alpha. Mean, that would be risky
though. If you wait till your opponent runs
get nodes and get pods and it looks
okay, and then you're like, go.
Cluster chaos.
Okay. So helium came back up.
I'm gonna make that happen, Russell.
Definitely.
Sorry. I was just just funny. We have
we have actual
rules.
Okay. Our application
still cannot reach the database. We still have
no networking at our pods.
Alright.
We've got sixteen minutes remaining.
Maybe we could peek at the hint, the
first ten? I think we yeah.
I mean,
what what do you think? What are you
thinking?
Well, I'm I'm wondering,
did he mess with core DNS? Because that
would but that would also because the pods
use that for a network resolution. Right? I
mean,
you could test
that. You could try pinging.
Oh, we we don't have ping. You could
There was a
I can just run a container and see
if that container
explodes.
Right?
Yeah. If you so if you want to
confirm whether this is DNS or not, you
can jump back into the cluster pod.
We can try and do something with an
IP address rather than a
DNS name. Right?
Yeah. I'll share that message from Carlos as
well, actually. We do have a bit called
Rawkode
Discord run by Carlos, Walid and others join
at Rawkode.chat.
Sorry, William.
Okay.
So you're back in the custard pod.
Except for I need to do one thing
first.
That service should have an IP. Right?
You can't ping a service IP, but you
could ping oh, but you don't you don't
have access to ping anyway in the container.
So you're gonna have to, like, curl a
public IP address.
Okay.
Let's see here. So why don't you sorry.
Exit
this container
and then do a ping Google.com,
grab the IP address, jump back in the
container, and then try
that. Oh, you got IPv6.
I did not do anything IPv6, which I'm
very proud of. Yeah. It's very tempting, but
I didn't I I I resisted. Yeah. That's
not gonna work. Yeah. Oh, yeah. But you
can call 4.
Yeah. 6. 4.
There. That works too. Oh, yeah. Didn't know
that. That was the thing. That's cool.
Yeah. They have one so that if you
have problems with I p v six, you
can jump in and talk to Google directly
on that. Nice.
So let's curl that or
It worked. We'll do a dash v and
a dash
k,
which will just get past Oh, yeah. It's
like thing.
Ignore the
do even need the p? You don't need
the p.
Okay. Well, there's a v which is for
for both. But you've done something cool. You've
confirmed this DNS.
It's always DNS. Right?
When in doubt okay.
So if we go
out of curiosity, google.com.
Yeah. Okay. Nothing. Okay.
Let's see here. Thirteen minutes left.
And a DNS look at that hand.
Okay.
So DNS
is running but
is ten days old. So he didn't do
question is, what did he do to it
that he didn't modify it?
Or did he fake it out?
Well, that just yeah. That's a pod that's
ten days old. Right? So he's not restarted
the core DNS pod, which makes it unlikely
that he has modified
the core DNS config.
So this is a host DNS
problem?
Well,
which would be on the workers. Right? Because
but that
it never gets to the host if it's
on core DNS because it would talk directly
to
it would talk directly to it. Right? We're
not we're not getting off of this this
system. We shouldn't be getting off the system
to talk to Postgres.
Well, the way that these clusters are configured
is that
I mean, he could modify the host file
on each of the machines, or he could
have set up system to resolve or something
like that.
So Postgres is the name. Right? Yeah. Try
fully qualified. So Postgres dot default dot s
v c dot
cluster dot local.
Okay. Do we have dig in this container?
Of course, we don't do that. That'd be
handy. No. No.
I don't know. And dig is not there's
a package for it. It's always it's a
package in every Oh, yeah.
Or
buying details or
Okay. I think I think with eleven minutes
left, we should probably look at the hints
file. Well, our audience is telling us
cluster first is an option.
But because the pods didn't restart, I I
don't think it is.
Get service.
I could've just deleted the
service.
It's Ten days old. Kube DNS.
Oh.
And we don't use ingress for any of
this stuff.
Did we check policies
in all What? Namespaces?
The
postgres service was modified though. That's interesting.
Was that us?
You already checked that. What's the first thing
we looked at? Yeah. It looked okay. Yeah.
Alright. Let's check for network policies in all
namespaces.
Okay.
Oh, yeah. Because the name were yep. That
makes sense. Because we checked net poll, but
we didn't check and we checked CCNP,
but I don't think we checked CNP
or all namespaces
and net poll.
Yeah.
And net poll.
Okay. That goes that.
Alright. We're under ten minutes. Yeah. Let's go
for the head. Let's do it.
Alright.
Hint one.
Okay. We did we did that one, cilium.
Yep. That one's already complete.
Don't mess with Sorry.
Damn it, Arnean.
Is there a way to dump the BPS
thing so Selen can re recreate it?
There there's also a hint three if
I would look at hint three as well.
Yeah. Let's If you okay. Let's narrow this
down before we start, Hunt. There's just one
more problem to fix with the cluster. There
there's just one. So
Ah, okay.
Let's take a look at the system control
services.
So I think adding is running any program.
So he's not using firewalls to block our
traffic. He's using a probe or something.
Alright. So you're gonna tell me about this
because I System control status.
So this will list all of the
the unit files.
Okay. So our queue balance container d.
Yep. So that looks good.
Those look fine.
We're just looking for something suspicious.
Unattended upgrades.
Hellport's Yep.
Those look good.
Is that the end?
That's the end.
Alright. We must have missed the one. Oh,
no. You have to look on the workers,
not the control plane. Uh-huh. This is another
yeah. So
Okay. Yeah. Okay. So I really have to
SSH into the control workers. Can you get
me there? Uh-huh.
Alright. I'm on worker one. Feel free to
pop, join that session.
Oh, okay. Let's see here.
Sessions.
Worker one. Join session.
Okay.
Echo.
Yep. Good. I see it's live.
Export.
Oh, you just need to look at system
d. I don't care about the KubeConfig.
I don't want there's a KubeConfig on the
work Oh, that won't matter. Yeah. Because it
doesn't have access anyway.
Alright. So system control.
And then what was the Status.
Status. And then you just have to remember
every service from the last one.
Container d I q balance.
There. Actually, this had its own. Yeah. It's
got its own pager. There we go. That's
better.
What do we got?
Why is there a serial?
That's okay.
Toolkit service, network dispatcher,
multi path,
accounts Damian.
Yeah. Let's go there. There's lots of stuff
here that wasn't there before.
Out of memory Damian.
That's the end of it.
Oh, I'm not seeing Oh, it used to
the pager.
Yeah. Hold on.
Let me try that again.
Okay. Yeah. Paging on my screen.
Yeah. It's been weird for me, but that's
okay.
Alright. So in a system,
IRQ is
Okay. So that's ambassador.
Selium agent, Selium health responder.
It looks less obvious in this system CTR
status than I would have hoped.
There's at the
alright. Let's see if we can just see
a rogue process.
Sleep one.
Who's sleeping?
That's a good question.
Maybe that's,
important.
Alright. So let's do that with a tree.
We have here, session ID.
Oh, that's your grep.
There's grep in this the journal stream.
Oh, yeah. I I should because I'm gripping.
Yeah. You're right. Sorry. Yeah. My
bad. Oh, okay. I should have done the
grip with a dash b or whatever it
is. Dash b five
will show you five lanes before. You could
do that. Yeah. I was gonna throw it
in the lesson, just search it out.
Let's
do a b five, then you get the
before five. Right?
So sleep.
Oh, so it's the system d m d.
Yeah. Okay.
It's great. Ominous.
So we can go to
and here and this is your system D
unit files. So I guess
you wanna be looking at an OM D.
Right?
Or or whatever you want.
Yeah.
But I don't see OM D.
What? It's it's system d dash OMDI.
Need to
Jack start.
I think that binary is a script.
Well, let's go check it out. Okay. But
don't cat it, please. We've already had that
this week.
What? I'm
showing my inability to use them.
Quit. That makes you you that makes you
human.
Okay.
There we go. Oh,
isn't too bad. Oh, yeah. But if it
was a bainer Oh, there's gonna be a
tool.
Okay. Here. I can solve this problem.
So,
I mean, you can delete the script, or
you could just disable the service.
Or I just change this to false, and
it'll never run.
And then I can restart the service.
Like that? I think it's very polite to
leave his rogue script service running. Thanks.
Thanks. I need that for tomorrow.
Okay.
So
but the thing is that's
We might have to restart Cilium for things
to get
Yeah. Because it's it's adding stuff to Right?
Yeah.
So okay. Well, let's let's try the easy
route. We're running out of time here.
Oh, you can't do that here. He only
needs to jump back over to the control
plane.
Oh, no.
Okay. I'll do some quick typing while you
come over.
Oh,
I like it. You're the label. Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
Also,
just because we've got two minutes, make sure
we get pods are white and make sure
we fixed it on the right node and
we haven't.
Oh, no.
So let's just delete the Let's
just hope it gets scheduled We can hit
the notes that it won't
it won't run on the other node?
Let's just cheat.
I think it's the
So where's template?
Spec.
Oh, okay. I'm gonna have to do this
on
here.
Templates back.
RNVP
worker
one.
Cool.
Okay. So that's not work. Hit the right
IP address of that worker because the other
one is still gonna be
funky.
So
yep. I think it did. Oh, and you
have to move Postgres call too.
It worked.
It worked. Alright. Cool.
Postgrescal's
still working on the wrong one. Wait. Fifty
seconds left. Yep.
Wow. Added.
I mean, it's harsh harsh.
I wanted to do something nasty with but
I didn't know what. So then I just
decided, I'll just delete all the programs that
Cillium inserts. I don't know what that will
do
because I don't know how BPF works, but
I suppose deleting all of them should break
things.
But I'm glad you opted for the delete
because if you had put something in,
I don't think we would have known how
to delete them.
Yeah.
That would have been a lot trickier. So
Yep.
Alright. Nice one.
Good job, William.
Yeah.
Yeah. It was very, very cutting very close,
but we made it. Fifty seconds on the
timer. That's good.
Alright.
Let's pop open.
The bit is on the other foot.
So control
plane
one. Okay. I've just opened a session, RN.
Okay.
Active sessions.
Yep. Got it.
So set up your KubeConfig. Best of luck.
William and I
will be here.
K.
Access denied.
So it is there, but I cannot connect.
Did you create your own session instead of
joining?
No. I joined the new session. You
didn't change his role.
Oh.
Yep.
Wait. No. You Well and now and now
the session also disappeared. It was there, and
now it's not there anymore.
Yeah. But I didn't give you access to
those machines, actually.
The the the session shows up even though
you don't have access. You just can't connect
to it.
Oh. I thought That's weird.
Okay. Well, it did, and then it didn't
anymore. Some weird race condition thing. Okay. You
should be good now.
I'm in. Mhmm.
It's a good thing Teleport makes that so
easy.
I really love Teleport. It's such an amazing
tool.
Hey.
Working cluster. Job done. I'm going to the
pub. I'll see you later. We're done. Okay.
So
this also works. It does. Okay. Let's pull
it up just so we can see the
the watch. I'm
so happy that it's working. Hello.
Yep. There we go. Watch. Watch. Watch.
K. So
let's
edit the deployment.
Right? So let's update.
It should be easy. Right? It's Friday night.
We're deploying.
Oh, it was the best time to deploy?
Yep. Yeah. Wait. My
exactly.
No. Oh.
It's been a while since we've seen an
HCD error message.
Okay. So could there be patched HCD server
permission denied?
Interesting.
Do we have at CD pods running?
We do.
Some stuff restarted. That's also on the s.
But it was before
the cluster
what?
Fourteen hours ago, but the age is 13.
Okay. This is I'm gonna ignore that for
now. Routing header.
Yeah.
When
okay. So
something something at c d.
But
we can read from at CD because all
these commands are working.
Well, I mean, we haven't tried to schedule
anything new, so we're not really sure.
Well, that won't work.
So we cannot schedule something new.
I think we'll need to take a look
at those logs.
Can I just do that with
they're running as a port? Right? And Yep.
We're about to
Great job. Yeah.
Failed to apply requests.
Okay.
Permission denied. Permission denied.
So it does not have the permission to
edit things.
Could
you have messed with the certificates
or something?
So it does say
off permission denied.
So
like, let's
and there's a cool bit of history,
which I think is cool. You see the
key on the ETCD thing here? It says
registry minions,
because that control play one. That's because
SaltStack used to be part of the original
deployment pipeline for Kubernetes.
Ah, interesting.
I didn't know that.
Okay. So I don't see
any files chain any certificates changed or anything.
That was my first gut feeling. Like, maybe
the client certificate was removed
or
a new client certificate was made that's I
don't know. But that's not it. Okay.
Does HCD have any kind of
ACL
features? I I don't know as much about
HCD.
No. I'm pretty I
mean, I may have this terribly wrong, but
my knowledge of this at the moment is
that it's just MTLS certificate level. So the
controller manager, the API server, the scheduler, etcetera,
all have their own certificates that will be
passed in via the static manifest to speak
to etcd.
Where are
it's good that you said it. I see
the API server etcd client certificates, but where
are the others? Oh, wait. Only the API
server talks to that city. Right? The others
all talk to the API server. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Okay. Never mind. I was like,
oh, I found it. So
but I would
maybe go take a look at the manifests
as well for the API server.
This also all looks very
not edited,
which in terms of
modification
date.
Well, all the FCD flags are at the
top.
Okay.
So at c d c I e file,
that makes sense. Cert file, key file.
Oh, the thing is it is connecting because
we're getting data out of the API server.
So Mhmm.
We've established that the
certificates have not been
modified.
Well,
we don't know for sure, but the modification
time
times
suggest that they haven't been edited. But
sure. I worked very hard to make sure
you could still see things.
Yeah.
I see that.
How is your entity knowledge adding in?
Zero.
I know that stuff
gets stored in there.
Alright. Well, let's get entity
cheat sheet Kubernetes.
I never remember how to configure the client,
but there's, like, three or four lines that
we need. And I always get it on
the same website.
Oh, yeah. Oh,
let's
you go.
Oh, we need to get the HCT client
installed first, but we can do that. I
know you're an XOS person, so I'll do
the the typing of the app install. So
just so you don't feel too dirty.
Oh, yeah.
Alright. There we go. If we get the
same error message. So this is an entity
thing.
Oh, but here we get the error message
on a get, which is interesting.
Right?
So we can't read either.
But why does the API server
still show things even though it can't read?
That's odd.
Right?
The only other entity command I know is
entity control health.
Sounds
like
Nope. Maybe not. State status?
I thought it was health.
I know one more. It's called test dash
help.
And
well, oh, look at this. There's something with
users and roles. And off. Oh, yeah. There's
lots here. Oh, endpoint health and endpoint status.
Okay.
I was almost there.
Do you want to try
off disable?
Sure.
So I don't know. I I just I
see it sitting there, and I'm like,
sure. We don't need authentication.
Oh, but it says username not found when
I do that. It's okay.
But it doesn't help us. Okay.
Can
we list all users? Will that work?
No. I already tried to give the same
error.
Alright. What about
role list?
Let me just type that.
Username not found.
Alright. Why don't we just try dash dash
user?
Root.
Oh, perfect shot.
Erin's back. Hello?
Yeah. I was talking to you. I didn't
actually realize you dropped. So Yeah. Yeah. No.
You're the entity. Fuck this. I'm away.
Exactly. I gave up.
So let's go let's
go look at the
the keys.
That'll have information on it. Right?
Okay. The keys. What do you mean?
The So if we go to p k
I at c t Oh, those keys. Yeah.
Sure. Yeah. Like, these are certificates that we
can try and remember the open SSL commands
to get some information out of these. Yeah.
Perhaps. And SSL
Dash
n. Yeah.
Wow. I remembered this. I'm so proud of
myself.
I had to look that up. Yeah.
Does it have anything?
Okay.
The subject alternative names looks good.
Doesn't look
so should be able to connect with local
host to the control plane to the control
plane's IP address. Does that match?
214.5.
Is that what we see here?
Yeah. This all looks very
not
weird to me.
Well, it it it makes you
Yes. Do we want to check whether it's
actually signed by the CA?
Don't know how to do that. But Well,
there's an interesting comment from Colin in the
chat who says it seems fishy about the
username has a space in it. Although,
he doesn't know much about SCD or if
that's expected.
No.
I don't think there I don't think there
are usernames when you're doing MTLS.
Right? It's just certificates. Yeah.
So I'm I'm not sure. Again, my etcd,
I wish it was
better than Okay. But let's
let's
what I wanted to look for is a
way to check if this thing is healthy.
Endpoint status and endpoint health. K.
Assuming that let's just run those commands.
Okay.
I'm curious, William. If we look at the
hands, will it guide us? Or
have you just left us here to to
I've just left you here. I've got notes
so I can drop in
hints and help if we get there. I
figured, you know, if we get down on
time a little bit. Yeah. We can work
this way. We're smart people. We're not we're
we're We're doing good. Yeah.
What what is an alarm? And we can
disarm it. I don't know. Was there an
alarm? The alarm list?
Yeah. There's no alarm. Yeah.
K. Don't know what alarm is, but I
was like,
it has a disarm command that sounds promising.
Yeah. That's such really annoying thing that we've
seen before where you can set the maximum
size of the database just so it can
be exhausted very easily.
And even if you change the size, you
still have to manually disarm the alarm before
it'll even work. That
bit me. So
this is a tricky one. I'm not.
Okay. Let's let's run that STD get command
again. Right? Let let's work out
what our error message is and see if
we can work work out what's going wrong.
Okay. I was like, what if I just
try to put in a new key if
that works? Okay. Did you say? Repeat what
you said.
We want to look at
Well, we got it's been so long there.
It feels like so long. But we got
we did get an error message about the
user when we try to when we do
the roles and user list. Right? So, like,
user
list. Yeah. It says username not found. But
I think that's because we don't have anything
here maybe.
But so we are
that's I think if you're doing standard authentication.
Right? So
let's let's see our setup for a TT
that we stole from the Internet. Right? Yep.
No. We've lost I've lost my buffer.
Here it is.
Now I've minimized Chrome. Hold on.
We'll get there. We'll get there.
Alright.
So
this is gonna be important. So set up
entity.
Now we're set in
I need to look at it for cat.
We're
setting up that we want API version three.
We're pointing it to the CA certificate so
we could validate that that's not expired or
anything, which may be good We're using a
weird
Oh, we're using a health check.
That that's that's not the right one. Right?
Okay. So let's use something with more permissions.
Yeah. The peer certificates, I suppose. Right?
Or even just the Yeah.
Well, sir, I don't know. Can can the
server that's the server. No. We want the
peer one. That's the one that the API
server probably uses.
Oh, we can confirm that, can we?
Yep.
Here.
Okay.
And I didn't plus x it, so you
only have to source it.
And we have to source it anyway because
otherwise we don't get
still permission denied.
Okay. So let's look at the static manifest
of the API server and see what certificate
it uses just just to confirm.
Sounds good.
It is using API server at city.
That's
wrong,
right? That doesn't exist.
Should be peer.
Crt, right? Or
oh, no. Wait. Peer is just okay. I
always get these confused. Yeah. Think peers for
other entity members.
Yeah.
So we do have an API
server entity client.
Sir, thank you.
Yeah. Let's actually
let's edit this
Why is there an API serve or entity
client and an API server dot sir? But
can we just see the timestamps of all
these files?
Well, that all look fine.
Why have we got two sets of API
server?
In fact, three sets of API server stuff.
Is that normal? I'm I'm starting to doubt
everything. Yes.
Yes. So I think API server is the
serving certificate.
The API server, kubelet client is to talk
to the kubelet server to get the logs.
This all looks normal to me so far.
But that
yep. So far.
But I want to Carlos.
Sorry
about him?
I said Carlos from chat agrees that
that's the one you wanna use.
Alright. Okay.
So we want to use the one from
the API server. Right?
Yeah. That's just API server dash h c
d dash client.
Alright. Let's source that.
We got stuff?
Yep. Okay. That works.
That's good.
I guess. So now can we list users
and roles?
I don't think so.
No.
Looking for hints in the chat.
Look how NCD server got started and with
what flags. Yeah. That's oh, yeah.
That's alright. I I I I was just
gonna list the the difference. Because what I
was thinking was there must be some certificate
here with elevated privileges even if our API
server doesn't have them. But that's a good
idea to look at the flags on HCD.
So let's do that. Yeah.
The key file,
that looks okay.
Here, client cert off.
This all looks normal to me.
So can't we just use the server dot
key and then we'll have root on that
CD?
Maybe. I'm not sure if you can use
the server certificate as a
buying certificate, but we can try.
But
okay.
Let's try it.
I mean, we have to see here. If
we also knew what we wanted to generate,
we could build a new certificate.
Right. I'm gonna leave this in.
I don't have to type it again later.
And if we can't use that, the peer
must be able to write, consider an entity,
etcetera. Right? This is
yeah. But this is the first one we
tried, and that one didn't work. So,
no. You did you source it? Oh, I
need to no. I did not.
Alright. Let me expect
to mess up the peer certificate.
You messed up. Come on.
Oh, is that is that a Messed that
up anyway.
Is that a hint?
Let's do a little command
on the peer cert and see what we
can see.
Sure.
My my other feeling is to just regenerate
the certificates
and restart
everything.
We could use a QVDM.
Yeah.
I remember I've never used this.
Oh, it wants me to.
So you would have to apply a phase.
So
So renew won't help us.
What does this do? I have a feeling
this command can help us, but I don't
know. Well, we could generate a new certificate
key.
You pay the m
cert certificate
keys
or key.
That's that's help.
That's what I meant.
Flags.
Print out the security. Okay. This is not
what we need. Yeah. We need to run
the the Kube ADM phases, I think. I
think you're right.
And
then there is a.
Yeah.
Serres.
So let's just do the
API server, STD client, or you could do
all, I guess. But
we don't wanna we probably don't wanna change
the CA.
No. Exactly.
Ah, okay.
But we can
guess we can move them. I was gonna
say delete them, but sure. Moving them seems
safer.
Yeah.
API server at Citi client dot
cert.
It.
Now,
do I need to restart the API server?
Well, why not try sourcing our file and
seeing if we can run the GET?
Assuming we've got it set up still.
Yeah.
It's in the folder.
Yeah. Let's get But now I'm happy that
I left the comments here. Right?
Because we probably also need to regenerate the
server certificates because that was also
okay?
We're in.
That looks promising, right?
You know, to try and add it. Yeah.
So
I wonder if the API server has the
keys cached in memory.
Yeah. So
how about this? Well, that won't work.
Does it not? Oh. I would restart the
pods. Yeah. Okay. So I just delete the
pod, and then it should Oh, you can't
delete the pods. You'll need to kill the
process.
That's annoying. Oh, because it's a step because
it's a static pod. Right?
Well, yeah. Well, it just yeah. It won't
delete. Although, it's not rained to HD for
the static pod. So you may actually be
able to do a cube control delete on
that because it's a shadow pod.
Right?
Maybe. Let's let's try it. Yeah. Because it's
that that never writes to NCD, so it
may actually work.
Oh, wait.
No. No. Just delete the process. Yeah. Yeah.
And then it's
+1 7818.
1 7
8 1 8.
And it should be back.
Wait. Let's just see if this now works.
No. It still is broken.
You
just restarted the API server, right? Yeah.
Just the API server.
There's some more things we need to restart.
So
Let's do you mind if I type? So
we run an EDC control get on a
key. Right?
Mhmm.
But we never tried
the so that's us configured with that new
search still.
So the Kubernetes rerunning
the search phase actually didn't help us.
No.
Which means
I'm just curious. Maybe we should just regenerate
all the certificates except the CA.
Do do you need to restart at CTs
also?
It
doesn't hurt at this point. Right?
Yeah. We could.
Done.
Okay.
Now let's try that command.
Yeah. Okay. So Nope.
I That was one of my thoughts as
how to fix it. So
I'm glad you tried that.
I don't think the stair is a problem.
So remember how I said
this thing about, there was a thing that
restarted, but it cannot be?
Uh-huh.
Maybe
should
not trust my initial instincts.
And
there's something funky with the controller manager and
the scheduler.
Maybe we've been But we but we can't
we can't use entity control locally either, which
is, like,
seems like a big flag.
Yep. That's that that is true. That is
true. So it is probably yeah.
But let's do do alright.
William, can we can we ask a question?
Yeah. Yeah. I was gonna offer a hint
at fifteen minutes.
It's not search. Right?
It's not
it's related to search, but the search are
not messed with. Yeah. That's what I was
thinking. Okay. So
and Etcd doesn't have a config.
Right?
Let's look at these flags.
Why didn't why has it taken us this
long to look at the FTD flags?
We look we look at them, I think.
Yeah.
Oh, I think I see it. I I
I The flags have a hint, but I
didn't change anything in the flags.
Oh, you you
didn't mess with the certificates. You didn't mess
with the flags.
I was thinking, oh, maybe the trusted CA
file was messed with, but no, that looks
good.
Right?
Does it? Yes.
There is
no, that also. There's client sort of off
in here twice.
But
Oh, his client start off and peer set
off.
What's
the volume amount on this? Carlos suggests checking
the failed system permissions, which again seems quite
obvious.
Maybe this is nothing to do That's what
I did last time.
Okay.
Volume mounts, etcd search.
Okay. Well, varlib etcd for the data.
That doesn't look good. Right? Does it? Wait.
No. It's at c kuban net t p
k I. Yeah. But that what if you
change the permissions on natural database fail
and Violet at c d?
But this is running as root. Right? So
let's go to viral web entity.
This all looks
beat, write, execute. This looks fine.
Right.
Yeah. This is all read write.
Okay. It looks fine. Yeah.
Okay. Do we want Do guys want a
hint?
Yeah. Let's do one.
Okay.
Roles
and users was the the right path in
my opinion.
So we need we need to find a
working
credible certificate
to speak to EdCT.
Right now we don't have one. Right?
User. Yeah.
Has he left this one in temp? People
are always nice that way.
No. I was not nice this round.
There's one special user and one special role
route. Okay. Right.
Did he see TL
user list.
User equals route. I tried to ask her
password.
What's the default? There's
a flag in your STD start that
that
gives you a hint on how you can
work around that.
There's Oh, we could turn client off off.
Yeah.
Like, client
off.
A client
there.
Okay. Who knows?
Client there off false.
Maybe it has to be before.
Yeah. Let's look at the flag. So Kubernetes
manifest.
There was this
here.
Oh, yeah. We could just restart STD without
oh.
What? Yeah. That's a very good idea.
Yeah. Yeah. Very good.
False.
And we don't need to worry about the
peer. Start off with not getting peers, but
yeah. Why not? Just turn it all off.
That that took a very long time.
Oh, I still have the password.
But
oh, this is doing Well, so maybe it's
not healthy yet.
Did I
did I oopsie yet?
Well, let's check the logs.
We may have to check it the old
school way.
Yep.
Oh, it's not started.
Why don't
because we are very smart people
sometimes.
Copy at cd.yam onto at c d dot
s h.
Well, we don't have add we we don't
have add c d on the host.
Right?
Give me a minute.
Okay.
And then shift j j j j j
j j j j Oh, no. I'll put
yammer. Alright.
Okay. We'll we'll reg x on that. I'm
getting a bit Rawkode.
Dash dash dash.
Oh. Oh, no. Yep. One less.
K.
Oh, no. That didn't work. Oh. Alright. No.
You replaced them all with g's.
Dash slash Slash dash. And then yes. Yes.
No.
Oh, wait. So we want to do this
but with a space. Got it. Yes. Damn
you. There we go. Alright. And then app
install. Etsy. Etsy.
Then let's just make sure our server doesn't
start up. Right? So This better be the
same version.
It's a server.
Well, someone already installed it.
No. It's trying to start it up immediately
afterwards,
I think. Alright. So bash@cd.sh.
Alright. That didn't quite work.
Less than metrics.
Oh, well, then well, maybe that's why it's
not starting up. We made a typo.
Right? I edited the file. Maybe I made
a mistake when we edited it.
Like, in the even in the YAML file,
that would explain it's not coming up anymore.
No. It's we need
Do we need to tell it the version?
No. Because there's no environment variables in the
manifest, is there?
I feel like I'm making this much harder
than it used to be.
Yep.
Oh, well. Thank you, I am. I'm here
trying to help you out.
No. It's fine.
It's fine.
That feels like it should work.
It's complete what what is the error that
it's giving?
Can we run one more time?
Not provided, but not defined. Let's see if
there's anything else. Why is there only one
dash?
I
I just support both syntaxes, and it's a
weird error.
Alright. Okay. I'm I'm gonna say this is,
a very old version of etcd maybe, and
maybe it's not even version three.
It is. Okay.
Did drop a hint in the root folder
for you.
I'm sorry. You're taking it off. I I'm
clearly not helping.
You are. You are.
Okay.
The certificate
CN is used as a username and at
CD when okay.
But, yeah, we currently don't even have a
working at CD. So
So we can always turn off back on,
put the manifest back, and then try this
Yeah. Common name as a username.
Although I feel like disabling client off and
logging in as root user should be okay
too. Right?
No. Because then you get then you hit
the password.
What's the default password?
They won't let you set one.
So The biggest admin or password. Where did
our s c d dot double go? It
said slash root. I put it there for
safety. Okay.
That's like that's
Alright. You'll need to put the client off
back on.
I feel like in the future, need to
if I do an ETD break, I need
to only do an ETD break and nothing
else.
Oh. There's more. No. That's fine. That's fine.
I'm gonna start using the
Okay. Thing that comes with k three s
where it's a SQLite database for state. It's
good. Says c d malarkey.
Okay. So the hint was the CN should
be the same. Right?
What is the CN in our case?
Yeah. I wanted to open SSL again.
Do you know how to generate a new
cert from a
CA?
QPDM does?
QPDM does. Yes.
Because you need you need a cert with
a common name of root because root is
the only
required
user in a TD.
I see.
We can
but I don't think we can choose
the certificate here. So we need to do
some
SSL commands.
Oh, yeah. And this is my my arch
nemesis
figuring out the syntax for.
Or can we maybe? No. I don't think
we can change the common name here. It
has only
predefined ones. Yeah. I think so too.
You know what? Maybe it's in the best
history. No. That was too easy.
We
want to So we can go to Kubernetes
a hard way on GitHub. Right?
Yeah.
Yes.
And search for open SSL.
Are they using c f s s l?
That's also fine.
Okay. So here's how we do this.
So we can copy.
Carlos is asking why won't regenerating work? Because
we need one with
CN route instead of CN
whatever we had.
Alright. So here's our CSR.
Yep.
That sounds looks good.
Let's just go here. CSR.
Oh, that's the best. And we want the
c yeah. And we want the c m
to be brute.
Yep. Right. So we can change that.
Yeah. We can keep all the other things,
I guess.
Stupid
thing.
Alright. So there we have a CSR.
We don't have CSSL though.
We can install it. That's good.
Alright. So,
now we can use c f I don't
remember these commands. I'm just gonna copy and
paste them.
Yep. We just need to put the right
CA dot PEM in here. Alright. So, let's
just call this same dot SH.
Mhmm.
So it's
are we in the directory
of
No.
So it's that's etcetera Kubernetes
p k I
At c d. C d c h dot
s r t.
Yes.
And then,
that's just
pti@ctca.key.
I don't have a c a config.
Maybe we can leave it away?
Should
this be
Yep. I suppose.
There is a syntax error in our in
our JSON.
K. We have keys. Okay. We have keys.
Let's modify.
Alright. ScratchAI@ct.
What did we call that?
It's route/route.cert.pem,
and the other one is routekey.pem.
Correct. Yes. Okay.
I know. It's root.pem and root-key.pem.
Why is there a connection refused?
Are we still broken at CD?
Yeah. I think so. I mean Wait.
It's not a Let me do this.
It's a static manifest.
Stop killing at CD.
No. But because she installed the package, they're
probably
oh, no.
We we made it worse, I think.
Did we?
ETCD is not running.
Alright. Let's restart the cuplet to encourage that
along.
Why can't I type?
Restart.
William, you're not invited back. I'm just in.
Okay. Okay. We got something. That's good.
Woo hoo. Uh-huh.
K.
Okay. We're brute.
That's the I Okay.
Turn off. Is this
How
do we disable
k. Boom.
Yep. There you go.
I mean, we could at least have tried
to fix the users and roles in another
thirty seconds. How hard could it be?
Yeah. One, cube admin doesn't set up those
things by default. So they're not even there
to begin with.
It's running.
It is.
It may just be cache for why we
don't have the dance.
This seems to work.
Right?
Or is this still the wrong version?
I
don't think it has the wrong version. I
think it's just I really need to call
the files something different.
But then curl, it's also serving me v
one.
But they always do v one.
Oh, also in v two? Yeah.
Oh. The only thing that changes the video
and that
isn't refreshing, but it could be cache.
But it doesn't look like it.
Because normally, would have reloaded by now.
Why is your helium crash loop back off?
Oh, probably because of your FTD.
Yep.
But this
yeah.
Okay. So we are I can just confirm
by doing source
to this.
It's the wrong one. We're still gonna v
one.
Unless this is the
There is a second level of evil, probably.
I I don't hear laughs. So Was
there more evil? That wasn't it? There there
there is more evil.
Still it's still v Okay.
There's some admission webhook running.
Some mutating webhook
that is
moving this back to v one. Alright. Just
because I now hate William so much, I'm
happy for us to go over by another
five minutes as long as you both have
the time.
Sure. Let's let's get rid of the mutating
webhook.
What what Configurations.
Mutating webhook configuration.
No.
Was a good guess though. Right? That was
a good guess.
Alright. So we modified the image. We saved
the manifest. It did not
take.
No.
It did not.
Let's look.
Change it again. I wanna see if the
revision bumps up to six
Yeah. Or seven.
Oh. Oh, it's
There's nothing to change here.
So
wait.
You can go back to
So where where did you see v one?
Did you describe the pod?
Yeah. The pod itself is still v one.
So he's
messed around with the controller manager or Kubelet.
That Well, the controller manager did restart. So
In
the interest of time, I used a
a validating webhook configuration.
A validating webhook configuration
that should not
be able to modify things. I'm confused.
Yeah. It can't modify things.
It can deny things.
But we didn't we didn't get it. Well,
maybe we did on the replica set.
That that validation dot d ns.kh.io,
that's that's not good. There's no such thing.
And that just makes it silently feel that
it's
Edit it. Go look at it real fast.
Yeah. Just so that everybody can see it.
Was there was there an error message when
we did the edit?
Nope.
Not on the deployment.
Not on the deployment, but maybe on the
replica set. Sneaky. Sneaky. Sneaky. Oh, yeah. Because
the deployment was v two. That's right. And
then the replica set was wasn't skilled up
because the one with the one on one
was ten minutes old. Gotcha.
That's a nice so we the part.
So
we have one with v one. Where's the
one with v two?
Well, if you deleted the webhook, then it
should just schedule. Right? So we're running it.
Well, I haven't delete I haven't deleted it
yet because that was interesting. Just in the
yeah.
Destroy it with fire.
No.
I don't want to get the yellow. I
want to get the name.
Why did they make this word?
It's horrible, isn't it?
K.
Alright. Rugged pots.
I don't want now. Let me
let me just delete the pods just in
case.
Do know what? Just delete the cluster.
Yes.
K.
There's a new prod.
That looks old. There's
there's more. There is more. Right? Four seconds.
This is good.
Okay. Okay.
Is this good or bad? That's bad. This
is not the right image.
Excuse me.
Pill policy always.
GHCR
Rawkode clustered v two.
Okay. Resolve conf.
It's always DNS.
You're gonna you're gonna wanna be in the
worker. Yeah.
Oh, yeah. But but you messed with DNS.
Yes. Okay.
Just as a cherry on top.
Yeah. That's under your rule. If you fuck
with Etsy, do you know how to mess
anything else up? Oh, just
redirects Etsy host.
Okay. Etsy hosts. We can delete it.
No. Don't Don't delete Etsy hosts.
No. No. But we can edit Etsy hosts.
Which server are you on?
I'm not on on
worker. I need to join your session still.
Are you trying to figure out on which
one the
pod got scheduled?
Ah, there we go. Yeah.
Remove that.
I'll do it.
Okay. So we need to delete the
pod again.
Me. You might wanna apply it to the
other worker real fast.
I never seen anything on the other worker.
It should be on both.
Yeah. I got stuck. I can
not access in on the other worker for
some Yeah. I accidentally ran it to the
I accidentally ran container d. Sorry about that.
Okay. Okay.
Now we're gonna delete this pod.
Then it's gonna
k.
DNS might be cached in core DNS as
well,
I suppose,
right?
I didn't intentionally break that. Yeah. You may
just wanna restart the kuplets on both workers.
Yeah. We can do that too.
And container d just in case.
Can you just try to type? I don't
think so. Oh, you can. Cool.
Mhmm.
And then we'll need to Oh, wait. I
guess because it pulled the image already. I
I checked that.
It will not re pull the image because
it already has it. I told it to.
Oh, okay. Okay. Interesting.
Alright. Let's go to work this time.
K.
Stop laughing, William.
Something
is writing to Etsy hosts con continually.
It's back.
I
did not do that. It was tempting. Oh,
okay.
Are we just saying I am incapable of
modifying a fail with them?
Because I don't think that's nice.
No. We we added it. It's but it's
still not working.
No. It's not working.
Okay.
Hint.
Yeah. Put us put us out our misery,
William. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm just like, what's going on?
Now you got me wondering.
Oh, no.
Where is that face?
I have one wait. I'm gonna just
This
Dash L space.
All right. Just in case, right?
We want to delete the part one more
time.
Delete the cluster. I'm done.
Try it.
It's mocking us.
Did you do a shift refresh?
I did. Many,
many.
I'm just gonna go back to v one
and call it a day.
We're we're back at v one.
That's what a true SRE does.
Right. We're like we're like v two again.
Yeah. Yeah. I I just have a feeling
it's not pulling the image for some reason.
Oh, no. Wait. The deployment changed. That was
always because I because
I searched for image. Oh. Always always in
the last applied configuration
but not down here.
That's
why.
So that means that William when he modified
it did server side apply with his coop
control.
Mhmm.
Okay. So go go to the page. I'm
dancing. I'm dancing.
Good.
Yeah. Nothing to say, William. Nothing to say.
In the STD break.
I I I feel that was cool. I
really enjoyed working through the STD break, and
then it was just sucker punches after that,
I feel.
See, I thought the other two would be
the easy one. The STD break, I expected
to take a while. I should have given
you a hint earlier.
No. No. No. No. It
was good. And I don't know. I just
you
don't think straight on these episodes. Like,
generating a new certificate
makes a lot of sense when you know
the username is a thing and it's a
special role.
Yeah. I still feel like turning off the
off should've worked, but you told me there's
no default password. So obviously, that's a bug
in etcd.
There's a reason why etcd makes you add
a root user and set a password to
it before it will let you do
turn on off.
And I set the password to one two
three four five six
so that you could That would have been
my next guess. Got that part.
I I I have deleted the cubelet on
the control plane and it's
it's done. It's done.
Yeah. I tried admin and I tried password.
I should have tried one two three four
five six. But
that would have been funny if if we
did it.
And, yeah, I I like the validation thing
because it was sneaky because the deployment edit
worked, but then you don't realize the pod
hasn't hasn't changed because you're too busy frantically
looking at everything else.
That that that is a bit of a
weird UX though. It would be nice if,
like,
the deployment would say, oh, this replica sets
that we created is not scaling up, like,
just from UX standpoint. Like, I know these
things are disconnected concepts, but as a user
Yeah. It's not very user friendly. Right?
And then So you you edit the pod
pod
when you edit the pod, it actually gives
you a real error, which was helpful. But
But you can't edit pods.
Yeah. They're immutable.
Oh, it's true.
So did you actually run your own registry
in that cluster or on the host somewhere?
No. I just I just
use container
d to download an existing container and then
retag it as yours. And then set the
if not present, and then it kinda snuck
through. But I only looked at the annotation,
which is why that trip is up to.
Damn it. Yeah. I originally put never because
I wanted to do it. And then I
was like, no. They you know, they're gonna
see that in five seconds.
That's too obvious. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Alright.
Good job, both of you. Great breaks by
both. Great fixes by both. As always, I
am the liability in the group and I
make everything take 10 times longer. But thank
you for your patience in sticking with me.
Thank you to our audience for watching. Thank
you to Equinix Medal and to Teleport for
their continued support,
and we'll see you all again soon. Have
a great weekend, everyone. Adios. Have a great
weekend. Bye bye. Bye.
For watching Rawkode Live.